here's eric fetty two-and-one in three
career starts against the phils
fetty gets another grounder it's his
specialty
garcia two now the designated hitter
bryce harper
that one's out to left center field
that's hit well it is gone
a long home run over the phillies
bullpen
number 12 for brice harper and the
phillies jump out to a one-nothing lead
it's the 48th run
they have scored in the first inning
this year look how easy this swing is
just nice and easy i'm going to hit a
line drive over the third base or
shortstop's head look at this
beautiful on balance
zach effluent on the mound tonight three
and two at the four two eight era second
start against washington in 2020 and
second start here in september's
fly ball to right field bruce it's not
deep he's under it makes the cap
stevenson tags he's heading to third the
throw by bruce and he is out at third
base
he doesn't catch it flat-footed he
catches it with some momentum and throws
a perfect one-hop strike to alec ball to
get stevenson at third base that's how
you that's how you play the outfield
big hook
second strikeout by zac eflin
he's retired three straight since the
soto basic
[Applause]
call strike three on the inside corner
three k's
for effluent
the 2-2
swing and a miss fetty strikes him out
on a high fastball fetty with his second
strikeout her sixth intentional walk
loads him up for rio muto
ground ball toward third
they go to second for one
harrison can't get it out of his glove
and hang on to it a rental score it's
two nothing phillies
it'll be an rbi for real muto
swinging this 95 on that fastball
five strikeouts for eflin
fly ball out to left field not deep
mccutchen
comes to his spot and puts it away
another one two three inning
ten straight retired by zach keflan
swing and a miss eric fetty
fast ball sinking action 93 strikeout
number four
chopper fetty to his right bare hand
good job good play
eight in a row for the nats right-hander
one out of runner at third nationals
trailing two nothing garcinia trying to
get them on the board
and garcia
gets the job done with a ground ball for
an rbi to gene segura now it's two to
one price leads it off
we go to the top of the sixth inning and
harper swings and hits one in the air to
left center field pretty deep taylor
back track wall leaps gone
bryce harper with another home run up
the alley and left center into the
phillies bullpen
he's gone deep twice tonight in the
phillies just like that reclaim their
two-run lead it's three to one but again
it you know it's a breaking ball by
fetty but it's down and away and just
look at the swing though luis garcia
gets a chance again
and the two strike pitch swinging i miss
he struck him out
and for zach eflin that's number seven
on the night seven strong innings under
his belt catching his one for three
doubled in the third they had the first
pitch for mcgowan
that one's hit well out to left center
field and it is
long gone a solo home run another one
for the phils
it's the third of the night have you
seen anyone get on top of a high fast
ball like he can now the bases are
loaded with one out and gene segura the
batter
and segura lines one to left field
that'll be in for a base hit one run is
in rounding third being waved home is
harper and he'll score sliding easily
it's a two-run single for segora uh zac
eflin on the mound will face uh eight
nine and one here in the inning and uh
called strike three right on the inside
part of the plate
nine strikeouts for effluent
six to one phillies lead at top of the
ninth inning two outs runners on the
corners indeedy gregorius who's one for
four
swings and lifts one deep right field
going back soto he looks up and that
ball is gone into the nationals bullpen
dede's 10th home run of the season a
laser to ride a three run home run and
it's a nine to one phillies lead
andrew slams it out to center field
back toward the wall it is gone
three run home run for andrew knapp
it's 12-1 phillies
take the night off boys start packing up
your bags boys head in
nine strikeouts one run on four hits
through eight he's sitting at 95 pitches
soto launches one to left
entertain us juan soto c
u
later his 13th of the year and now it's
12-3
joe girardi is going to take zac eflin
out of this ball game and uh but eflin
does his job tonight for sure pitching
into the ninth
fly ball out toward right field not deep
paisley in under it and he makes the
catch
and the ball game is over the phillies
win it 12-3